[Musique]
c'est la première chose à laquelle j'ai
pensé service mes cheveux soient jamais
une très grosse touffe de cheveux
je suis allé chez un coiffeur qui m'a
qui est spécialisée en fait qui reçoit
beaucoup de femmes qui me cancer et qui
s'occupe de ça et donc il m'a beaucoup
préparé beaucoup parlé beaucoup expliqué
son parcours justement pourquoi lui il
faisait ça et comment au fur et à mesure
il a su
expliquer aux femmes en fête qui allait
leur arriver et donc il a fait ça
c'était super m'a coupé les cheveux
d'eau miroir il m'a fait un shampoing il
m'a mis une serviette ni façon murard et
l'a attendu le bon moment pour m'enlever
et quand ils m'ont enlevé ses je me suis
découverte et je me suis découverte un
nouveau mois donc à ce moment là c'est
là qu'on j'ai accepté mon image en fait
j'imaginais quelque chose est en fait de
le voir on ne sait pas du tout ce que
j'imagine et je me suis trouvé à ce
moment et je m'habille même les dj va
voir quand j'ai enlevé la serviette d'un
grain de magnifiques ça te va super bien
ouais et en effet où j'ai trouvé ça
plutôt chouette
[Musique]
s'inquiéter c'est ouvrir un parapluie en
attendant la pluie en fait c'est que là
on imagine quelque chose on se fait tout
un film est en fait la vraie vie c'est
comme en se découvrant gré en petit bain
non c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
imaginé mais superbe comme on est c'est
ça qu'il faut faire c'est pas se passer
de dire il faut mais oui il faut croire
en soi you don't care
[Musique]